I'm wondering if you recommend chlorine dioxide, MMS, or CDS, or in other forms, and it's protocols.
So we actually scrubbed our website from any blog posts that we had on MMS because the FDA
came down at it so hard. So when we used to see a lot more lime patients, and testing them in
the clinic and things, they tested very commonly, tested positive for MMS, and we used lower doses
of MMS on those patients with really good success. It can be a good thing to treat acute infections.
Chronic lime typically not. So most chronic lime cases, the person is suffering from symptoms of
autoimmune disease, not from current exposure and current infection. Many times people with
chronic lime think that, oh, this burrelia is acted up again, it's flared up again, and I got to
try to kill it. And while that can be true, more often than not, it's not the burrelia acted up.
The burrelia is long gone. The burrelia, burbinography is the infectious agent,
number one, culprit of lime disease. But it's what damaged that burrelia did. It got inside the cell,
caused your immune system to try to kill burrelia, and it can end up making antibodies against the
cell. So you get it up with self-antibodies, aka an autoimmune disease, with any type of chronic
infection. And that may be more often than not what is actually causing the patient the symptoms.
So flayer taking place with somebody with a chronic lime or chronic viral infection, or
that they attribute to a chronic lime or chronic viral is actually quite often an autoimmune response.
So it's actually they're getting symptoms of an autoimmune disease. Their body is attacking
cell structure. They feel lousy. They think it's the lime acting up, but they're trying to use
things like MMS that could kill. So MMS would be a pathogen kill agent. It's not going to heal your
body. It's it's oxidizing and being an oxidizing agent, it's going to kill pathogens.
So just a little bit of understanding about that. Everybody's taking a lot of antioxidants. I mean,
that you see in natural circles, everybody needs more antioxidants. And you see Instagram,
YouTube, and TikTok, natural doctors talk about take more antioxidants. You need antioxidants in
order of survive, because the thought processes that we live in a poisonous world. So we're exposed
to different toxins, micotoxins, and heavy metals, and pesticides, and herbicides, and things.
These are oxidizing agents that the problem with oxidizing agents, they're they're poisons. So they
can damage ourselves. They can damage our DNA, and they can lead to cancer. So then we think, oh,
wow, I'm ready to take tons of antioxidants. I'm going to take glutathione. I'm going to take
ALA. I'm going to take all, you know, might see I'm going to take all these antioxidants, because
I don't want to get this disease. But we have to realize that our body is in has to be in balance.
Yes, oxidizing agents out of balance can cause damage. But our body actually makes oxidizing agents.
Our body will actually create reactive oxygen species in the presence of pathogens. So we're exposed
to a fungus or a bacteria or a virus. We'll actually make an oxidizing agent in order to kill
most things. So by taking high dose antioxidants for a long time, then we can hinder our body from
killing pathogens. Well, in balance, the other way can be a problem too. So if you're using something
like MMS, which is an oxidizing agent, because you know, you read somewhere that MMS is good for you,
and you're taking that on a daily basis, well, you could, you could be in balance the other way,
especially when we're living in this toxic world and we're exposed to even more oxidants. So we're
really oxidizing our tissue. That can lead to cell damage. That can lead to damage to your gut cells.
I can lead to damage of all your cells. I can lead to, it gets absorbed into the cell. I can
lead to DNA damage, which causes cancer. So it's all about balance. So if a person suspects that
they have a virus, or they suspect a bacterial infection, or they suspect a acute
Lyme disease, using an oxidizing agent for a short period of time can be beneficial to kill it.
But it's like anything, you have to keep that balance. You don't want to get out of balance either
away. Do I take antioxidants? Yes. Not cut not all the time, though. You should be pulsing these
supplements. So should you take an oxidizing agent? Well, yeah, like I said, if you think you're exposed
to an acute pathogens, that's where taking an oxidizing agent can be helpful. Actually,
using an oxidizing agent to treat cancer can be beneficial. I have cancer
bedburst patients that, you know, we'll say, I want to be on glutathione. That was a question
on our Zoom call last week. Should a breast cancer patient be on glutathione all the time? Well,
the answer is, well, no. If I tested them for glutathione, I tested positive for this period of time,
that yes, they should. But if not, you don't just arbitrarily go on high dose antioxidants,
which glutathione would be, to think that that's going to kill cancer. Well, antioxidants are going
to kill cancer. Antioxidants may protect one from cancer, but they're not going to kill cancer.
And in order to kill cancer, your body can be making reactive oxygen species to do that.
Cancer cells themselves are going to be more sensitive to cell death by reactive oxygen species
than healthy cells are. So you don't want to defeat that purpose. That's what chemotherapy is.
Chemo-therapies are an oxidizing agent. So it's killing cancer by oxidizing those cells and
cancer cells are going to be more susceptible to oxidation and damage and cell lysis to oxidation
healthy cells going to be because healthy cells produce its own glutathione or cancer cells because
they're a rapid replication are going to be able to produce as much glutathione.